Speaker 1: Still awake?
Speaker 1: Something on your mind?
Speaker 1: Give me a call, three two three-K-L-five-K-T-R-K.
Speaker 1: Ask to speak to the cute one.
Speaker 1: Hey, all you night owls, is the human race going crazy or is it
Speaker 1: just me?
Speaker 1: Seems like all you hear is bad news lately.
Speaker 1: Anybody feel the same way?
Speaker 1: Feel like the world's cracking at the seams?
Speaker 1: Why don't we make that the topic for tonight?
Speaker 1: And if that doesn't work, you can all go back to calling in with
Speaker 1: the usual pervert stuff.
Speaker 1: Line five, you're on with the Deb of Night.
Speaker 1: So tell me, society going to hell or not?
Speaker 2: I think so, Deb.
Speaker 1: And why is that?
Speaker 2: Well, for one, I lost my job a month ago, and our management gave
Speaker 2: themselves a bonus for it.
Speaker 1: I'm sorry to hear it.
Speaker 2: And just the other night, I happened to look out my window here in
Speaker 2: Santa Monica, which used to be a nice neighborhood.
Speaker 2: I saw the local diner where I've been eating my breakfast for years get
Speaker 2: shot to pieces.
Speaker 2: Can you believe that?
Speaker 2: Like, no one cares about anyone anymore.
Speaker 1: I hear it.
Speaker 2: And my neighbor's boy, sheesh, he's been using speed since he's in junior high,
Speaker 2: steals from his parents.
Speaker 1: That's a shame.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah.
Speaker 2: You know, there was a time when this sort of thing just didn't happen.
Speaker 2: You know why?
Speaker 1: Why is that?
Speaker 2: Well, because a man could beat a woman and children when they got out
Speaker 2: of line.
Speaker 2: They didn't even have to be blood.
Speaker 2: You could just slap the little bastards.
Speaker 1: Ah, the good old days.
Speaker 1: Why don't you hit the activity room and reminisce some more, Grandpa?
Speaker 1: Anyone have any musings that don't end up in assault charges?
Speaker 3: Yeah, hi.
Speaker 1: Whoa, here's a rare event, a female perspective that isn't my own.
Speaker 1: Go ahead, sister.
Speaker 3: Um, [clears throat] I just wanted to say that I agree with you for the
Speaker 3: most part.
Speaker 3: Things have really started to suck in the last few years.
Speaker 1: Mm-hmm.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it's like I can't see myself bringing a child into this world, you
Speaker 3: know?
Speaker 1: I hear you.
Speaker 3: Except if it was, like, Ash Rivers' baby.
Speaker 3: [gasps] Oh, he's so amazing, Deb.
Speaker 3: I would, like, populate a minivan for him.
Speaker 3: Oh my God.
Speaker 1: Yeah, but what are the chances of that happening?
Speaker 3: I don't know, but I'm, like, at his club every night.
Speaker 3: [chuckles]
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 1: But back to the topic.
Speaker 3: Oh, a-and this one time, I was working as a waitress at this award
Speaker 3: show, and I served him a drink, and he told me, "Thanks, beautiful." And
Speaker 3: there was, like, a moment, definitely something there, you know?
Speaker 1: Sure, girl, but tonight's topic isn't Ash Rivers.
Speaker 3: Yeah, well, that's probably really good because all of you other females better stay
Speaker 3: the hell away from him.
Speaker 3: You know what I mean?
Speaker 1: I'm glad to provide a public forum for the whacked out of both sexes.
Speaker 1: Let's try to stay on topic, shall we?
Speaker 1: Deb of Night?
Speaker 1: That's me.
Speaker 1: I recently found out I was a vampire.
Speaker 1: [laughs] Oh, I was one of those once, and then it was November first.
Speaker 1: It's not a joke.
Speaker 1: I'm really worried about this.
Speaker 1: Uh-huh.
Speaker 1: This girl at the club took me into the bathroom, and she did something
Speaker 1: to me.
Speaker 1: Back in my club days, we used to call that a favor.
Speaker 1: Oh, caller, could you hold on?
Speaker 1: I've got Frankenstein on the line.
Speaker 1: Frankenstein, something you want to add to this conversation?
Speaker 2: Rah!
Speaker 1: I see.
Speaker 1: Your rebuttal, caller.
Speaker 1: I'm not lying.
Speaker 1: It happened to me.
Speaker 1: It could happen to anyone.
Speaker 2: Fire.
Speaker 2: Ah!
Speaker 1: Ooh, good point.
Speaker 1: You want some advice?
Speaker 1: Wash off the eyeliner, put on something that's not black, and go get a
Speaker 1: tan at the beach.
Speaker 1: Geez, the Deb of Night Show does not endorse the goth lifestyle, and take
Speaker 1: it from Deb, pretending you're a vampire only impresses people of similar physical ickiness.
Speaker 1: Next caller.
Speaker 4: Deb, I think the world's been messed up, is messed up, and will continue
Speaker 4: to be messed up.
Speaker 1: Oh, an optimist.
Speaker 4: Now, bear with me, but I know what the cause of all the world's
Speaker 4: problems is.
Speaker 1: Nipples on TV?
Speaker 4: Exactly.
Speaker 1: Nudity?
Speaker 4: Not too much nudity.
Speaker 4: Not enough nudity.
Speaker 4: Clothes make a person dishonest.
Speaker 4: They're hiding their true selves away under them.
Speaker 4: Clothes promote problems like class and sense of piety and concealed weapons.
Speaker 4: Why, how much do you think we spend on clothes as a people?
Speaker 4: What if that money were going towards science?
Speaker 4: Why, we'd be living in a futuristic techno world by now.
Speaker 1: Have you ever been to a nudist colony?
Speaker 1: Not attractive.
Speaker 4: The fact that you think it should be is a side effect of the
Speaker 4: prurient media.
Speaker 4: You're not desensitized to nudity.
Speaker 4: Just think, if the man at the movie concession wasn't wearing his pants today,
Speaker 4: you'd storm out of the theater in a tizzy.
Speaker 4: But in a nude world, it'd be, "Popcorn and a medium soda, please."
Speaker 1: No, I think what would happen is I'd lose my appetite.
Speaker 4: And isn't obesity one of our nation's biggest problems?
Speaker 4: Another benefit of nudity.
Speaker 4: And what about all that hullabaloo that people make when a person walks around
Speaker 4: the way Mother Nature made him on a brisk spring afternoon?
Speaker 4: Arrested for public indecency?
Speaker 4: Why, in a nude world, it'd be commonplace.
Speaker 4: Folks would ask you, "How many people did you expose yourself to today?"
Speaker 1: As proud as I am of my girls, I think I'm gonna limit them
Speaker 1: to private appearances.
Speaker 1: Next caller.
Speaker 5: Deb, this is it.
Speaker 5: This time I've stumbled across something that's bigger than anything you could possibly imagine,
Speaker 5: a threat to the entire human race's existence.
Speaker 1: Ah, Gomez.
Speaker 1: You know it's been a bad night when I've been looking forward to your
Speaker 1: call.
Speaker 5: Deb, nothing can prepare the world for this.
Speaker 5: This is the biggest story in the history of humanity ever.
Speaker 5: Ever, Deb.
Speaker 5: How I found this out, I can't say, but I'm risking my life to
Speaker 5: tell the world this.
Speaker 5: Are you prepared for this?
Speaker 1: Sure.
Speaker 5: People of Los Angeles, vampires walk among us.
Speaker 1: Ugh, not vampires again.
Speaker 5: Hear me out, Deb.
Speaker 5: Vampires are among us and have been since the dawn of time.
Speaker 5: In Los Angeles, well, there's more vampires per person here than anywhere else in
Speaker 5: the world.
Speaker 5: People are killed by vampires all the time, but their secret vampire society covers
Speaker 5: it up.
Speaker 5: Who blew up that warehouse in Santa Monica?
Speaker 5: Vampires.
Speaker 5: What happened to the crew of the Elizabeth Dane?
Speaker 5: Want to know what happened to that sarcophagus that disappeared?
Speaker 5: Vampires took it.
Speaker 5: The Prince of Vampires, to be more specific.
Speaker 5: He wants to use it against a league of other vampires that have been
Speaker 5: trying to get a foothold in our city.
Speaker 5: And get this, there could be an even older vampire in the sarcophagus, an
Speaker 5: ancient super vampire.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 1: Vampires, they're everywhere.
Speaker 1: You can't throw a rock in the city without hitting a vampire.
Speaker 6: Our overlords before it's too late
Speaker 1: You heard him, folks.
Speaker 1: Gather up your crosses, garlic, and neck braces.
Speaker 1: Oh, brother.
Speaker 1: Well, Deb's not undead, but the sun'll be up soon, and she's dead tired.
Speaker 1: She's going home to get some hard-earned R&R.
Speaker 1: But don't worry, she'll be back same time, same station tomorrow night.
Speaker 1: Until then, fans, don't let the vampires bite
Speaker 7: In a world where people live and die
Speaker 6: Do you think you can just go in there and handle this by yourself?
Speaker 7: If that's what it takes.
Speaker 7: He was about to meet his greatest foe.
Speaker 6: Kill them all.
Speaker 6: All of them.
Speaker 7: And a girl.
Speaker 6: Hello.
Speaker 8: Hi.
Speaker 7: And a comic relief sidekick who won't make it to act three.
Speaker 6: I picked the wrong month to cancel my life insurance.
Speaker 7: No, don't say that.
Speaker 7: You're gonna make it.
Speaker 7: With a guy from that other movie that was slightly popular, and what's her
Speaker 7: name, from that show you sometimes watch.
Speaker 7: In a movie with two spectacular CGI battle sequences and an advertising campaign that
Speaker 7: will leave you no choice but to see this film.
Speaker 7: See it because it's a movie, and all your friends are going.
Speaker 7: In theaters Friday and on DVD in three months
Speaker 9: Friggin' Chicken recently challenged several random people to a taste test between Friggin' Chicken
Speaker 9: and the other leading chicken flavored products.
Speaker 9: Let's listen for which one they preferred
Speaker 8: Ma'am, care to participate in a taste test?
Speaker 8: Here, try this leading brand of chicken.
Speaker 10: Ugh.
Speaker 10: Oh my gosh.
Speaker 10: Is that week-old fish?
Speaker 8: Now, try this.
Speaker 10: Oh.
Speaker 10: Oh, this is some good [beep] chicken.
Speaker 10: What is this?
Speaker 8: Sir, take a test for me?
Speaker 6: Sure.
Speaker 6: [munching] Seriously, jog these up your [beep].
Speaker 8: Here, try this one.
Speaker 6: Mm.
Speaker 6: Hey.
Speaker 6: Mother [beep] great chicken right there.
Speaker 6: What is this?
Speaker 8: It's Friggin' Chicken.
Speaker 6: This is cat, right?
Speaker 6: Are you feeding me cat?
Speaker 8: Try this.
Speaker 6: Holy [beep].
Speaker 6: [beep] that's good.
Speaker 6: What the [beep] is this [beep]?
Speaker 9: Nine out of 10 people preferred Friggin' Chicken over the competition.
Speaker 9: Why?
Speaker 6: 'Cause that's some good [beep] chicken.
Speaker 6: I mean, Friggin' Chicken.
Speaker 9: Friggin' Chicken, you'll swear it's the best you've ever had.
Speaker 9: [horn honking]
Speaker 8: Phil's here.
Speaker 8: Gotta run.
Speaker 8: Great breakfast, honey.
Speaker 10: Have a good day, dear.
Speaker 10: I'm glad you liked the muffins.
Speaker 8: Hey, what's that on the counter?
Speaker 8: That's not my margarine, that's butter.
Speaker 10: It's [punching] [beep].
Speaker 8: You know I'm supposed to watch my LDL levels.
Speaker 10: [crying] I, I thought it would be a nice change.
Speaker 10: You couldn't even tell.
Speaker 8: You don't want a divorce, you're trying to kill me.
Speaker 8: I'm glad I slept with your sister.
Speaker 8: [door slamming]
Speaker 9: I thought it was margarine, grade B butter.
Speaker 9: Other ants who tasted margarine with all the saturated fat of butter.
Speaker 9: [horn honking]
Speaker 8: Phil's here.
Speaker 8: Gotta run.
Speaker 8: Great breakfast, honey.
Speaker 10: Have a good day, dear.
Speaker 10: I'm glad you liked the muffins.
Speaker 8: Hey, what's that on the counter?
Speaker 8: That's not my margarine, that's butter.
Speaker 10: It's [punching] [beep].
Speaker 8: Bitch, you know I'm supposed to watch my LDL levels.
Speaker 10: [crying] I, I thought it would be a nice change.
Speaker 10: You couldn't even tell.
Speaker 8: You don't want a divorce, you're trying to kill me.
Speaker 8: I'm glad I slept with your sister.
Speaker 8: [door slamming]
Speaker 9: I thought it was margarine, grade B butter.
Speaker 9: Other ants who tasted margarine with all the saturated fat of butter.
Speaker 9: You loved the talking baby movie, and the talking pig, and even the talking
Speaker 9: car in that show.
Speaker 9: You know the one I'm talking about.
Speaker 9: But now prepare for the most hilarious, talking-est, normally mute object yet.
Speaker 9: He's Steve Cash, a New York banker and recent widower down on his luck
Speaker 8: And 10 makes 100.
Speaker 8: Here's your money, ma'am.
Speaker 8: Ma'am, I happen to have a glandular problem.
Speaker 8: That's it, I'm withdrawing all my millions from this bank.
Speaker 6: Cash.
Speaker 6: [laughing]
Speaker 9: She's an ATM machine with the soul of his dead wife
Speaker 8: There's something familiar about this ATM machine.
Speaker 6: I love you.
Speaker 8: Wow, those marketing guys are geniuses.
Speaker 8: [laughing]
Speaker 9: Together, they're learning to make the most of their special situation
Speaker 6: So that girl from accounting used me today.
Speaker 8: Really?
Speaker 6: She wasn't like everybody else.
Speaker 6: When she pushed my buttons, she was very gentle.
Speaker 8: Oh, honey, if you don't stop, I'm gonna have to make a deposit.
Speaker 8: [laughing]
Speaker 9: Transferring Cash, Wednesdays at 8:30 in the BMC.
Speaker 9: Does your penis always seem to be getting in the way?
Speaker 6: I got the last of the groceries, honey.
Speaker 6: I just need to close the trunk.
Speaker 6: [trunk closing] [screaming]
Speaker 8: One more nail and this birdhouse will be as good as new.
Speaker 8: [hammer hitting wood] [screaming]
Speaker 10: I'm sorry, sir, this dressing room is for women only.
Speaker 7: You don't have to let this happen to you.
Speaker 7: Hi, I'm Dr.
Speaker 7: Fred Tuck.
Speaker 7: Don't let your penis interfere with the quality of your life anymore.
Speaker 7: I have performed over 300 sex changes in my career, and not one of
Speaker 7: my patients has ever asked for their tackle box back.
Speaker 7: Come to Tuck's Sex Exchange in the next month, and I'll give you a
Speaker 7: free estimate.
Speaker 7: Don't let your piece interfere with your peace of mind
Speaker 9: Tuck's Sex Exchange, located off Beverly Drive.
Speaker 9: Look for the sign with Toothy, the surgical saw.
Speaker 9: You live.
Speaker 9: [birds chirping] You die.
Speaker 9: [bell tolling] And sometimes you get brought back to life.
Speaker 9: [lightning striking] [zombie growling] This fall.
Speaker 8: I'm afraid.
Speaker 8: I can't see too well these days.
Speaker 8: Do you think you could go to the nearest village and pick me up
Speaker 8: a loaf of bread?
Speaker 6: Bread.
Speaker 6: Good.
Speaker 9: The new horror RPG from Troika Games.
Speaker 6: Bread.
Speaker 8: Oh, I can tell you where the bakery is, stranger.
Speaker 8: But before I do, would you mind picking up my little girl from the
Speaker 8: lake?
Speaker 9: You are the monster.
Speaker 9: [woman screaming] Or are you?
Speaker 6: If you wanna enter this bakery, you'll have to defeat me, and this torch.
Speaker 6: [fire whooshing]
Speaker 9: Frankenstein: Breadlust, coming soon to a PC near you.
Speaker 6: Game.
Speaker 6: Good.
Speaker 8: Ah, would you look at this?
Speaker 6: What's that?
Speaker 8: Plague of locusts descend on small Indian town.
Speaker 6: Geez, I can't imagine what that must be like.
Speaker 8: And look at this.
Speaker 8: Civil war still raging between ethnic factions in Eastern Europe.
Speaker 6: Yeah, heard about that
Speaker 11: And in Zimbabwe, they got to use oxcarts for ambulances.
Speaker 11: That's terrible.
Speaker 11: Hey, it's a good thing we live in the US.
Speaker 11: It sure is, buddy.
Speaker 11: Hey, bartender, two more US ales.
Speaker 12: US Ale.
Speaker 12: Welcome to the United States of Inebriation.
Speaker 13: [singing]
Speaker 13: In the violet silence of a dream within a dream.
Speaker 13: You fill my soul with beauty, you're my shining man machine.
Speaker 13: Sinking in the roses falling down to free you, baby.
Speaker 13: Your velvet play of apathy makes the crush so bittersweet.
Speaker 13: And I, I could have died last night.
Speaker 13: But I heard the voice of a smiling god.
Speaker 13: [singing]
Speaker 13: Your presence is the morning, your absence is the night.
Speaker 13: I'm searching your dark hallways and I'm trying to find your light.
Speaker 13: Swimming your sad oceans, I'm drowning in your sea.
Speaker 13: This will all be over soon and we'll learn to live again.
Speaker 13: And I, I could have died last night.
Speaker 13: But I heard the voice of a smiling god.
Speaker 13: Bleeding stars, I see your eyes.
Speaker 13: I hear you speak to me.
Speaker 13: I miss you now so much it aches.
Speaker 13: So broken, so afraid.
Speaker 13: [singing]
Speaker 13: And I, I could have died last night.
Speaker 13: But I heard the voice of a smiling god.
Speaker 13: [singing]
Speaker 12: I bite, you bleed.
Speaker 12: You pray, I feed.
Speaker 12: You cry, I won't.
Speaker 12: You die,
Speaker 12: I don't.
Speaker 12: I recall
Speaker 12: when we were first introduced.
Speaker 12: You were tired
Speaker 12: and broken and confused.
Speaker 12: The walls you built kept crumbling in.
Speaker 12: Your life of lies hiding you within.
Speaker 12: Just one taste of nectar from this spoon.
Speaker 12: Now you can't walk away, tomorrow comes too soon.
Speaker 12: I bite, you bleed.
Speaker 12: You pray, I feed.
Speaker 12: You cry, I won't.
Speaker 12: You die,
Speaker 12: I don't
Speaker 12: I will make you feel this way forever.
Speaker 12: I am the only one us to stay together.
Speaker 12: I will never turn away, I am not afraid.
Speaker 12: I know you could never wipe my kiss away.
Speaker 12: Clench your hand into fists.
Speaker 12: Hold me as we kiss.
Speaker 12: I know you can't pull away.
Speaker 12: Our hot love fills your veins.
Speaker 12: I bite, you bleed.
Speaker 12: You pray, I feed.
Speaker 12: You cry, I won't.
Speaker 12: You die,
Speaker 12: I don't.
Speaker 12: So you've lost count of days since I came
Speaker 12: to take your pain away.
Speaker 12: Now you don't have the strength to survive.
Speaker 12: Your last sign of liberation
Speaker 12: is to the needle's eye.
Speaker 12: I
Speaker 12: bite, you bleed.
Speaker 12: You pray, I feed.
Speaker 12: You cry, I won't.
Speaker 12: You die.
Speaker 12: I bite, you bleed.
Speaker 12: You pray, I feed.
Speaker 12: You cry, I won't.
Speaker 12: You die,
Speaker 12: I don't